hi welcome back to our series on
embedding looker
previously we walked you through how to
embed a looker dashboard with custom
filters
now let's dive into another common
embedding use case you can try out
dynamically changing a looker embedded
dashboards layout
let's say you have a looker dashboard
embedded in an iframe in your host
application's front end
the dashboard contains multiple tiles
we want to give the user a more
interactive experience
so let's add a button in your host
application front end that hides a tile
in the embedded dashboard
poof
this dynamically changes the layout of
the embedded dashboard
we will use JavaScript
and our embed SDK to implement the
feature
you can also use plain JavaScript
without the embed SDK 2.
at a high level we will follow these
implementation steps
we will listen for an event emitted by
the iframe that tells us the dashboards
layout then we'll determine the new
dashboard layout AKA which tell it to
hide
lastly we'll set up a new button to
message the iframe to update its layout
we have a working code sample in our
embed reference Repository
links below
keep in mind the code sample is more
complex and makes use of react
we'll walk through a simpler example in
this video
as always a Quick Knowledge check before
we continue
you should be familiar with JavaScript
HTML the looker dashboard and the looker
embed SDK
[Music]
all right let's get started by listening
to the iframe
the embedded dashboard in the iframe
will emit events that communicate
changes in its state
we want to listen to the dashboard
loaded event that fires when the
dashboard and its tiles have loaded but
its queries are not yet running
the event will tell us the layout of the
dashboard
so
how do we listen to this event
we first go through the basic creation
of an embedded dashboard we call the
embed sdks create dashboard with ID
method
then the opento method
and then the build method however this
time we also make a call to the on
method before the build method call so
we can listen to the dashboard loaded
event
we provide the on method with the
event's name
and an event listener function to handle
the event
also after the build method call we need
to chain a call to the connect method to
establish the sdk's communication with
the iframe and enable the event listener
let's determine what tile to hide to
dynamically change the dashboard layout
if we go back to our example we defined
an event listener function to listen to
the dashboard loaded event
the event listener receives the event as
an argument
this event contains an options property
which itself contains the dashboard
layout components property this property
consists of an array of layout
components each representing a tile in
the dashboard we can take this array and
update it to whatever dashboard layout
we want in this example let's update the
dashboard layout component to an array
with the first element removed
this effectively hides the first tile in
the dashboard
now our new dashboard options represent
the new layout we want
lastly let's set up a new button to
message our embedded dashboard to update
its layout
we first create a button in the Dom
next we set up the buttons on click
Handler to call the set options method
on the embedded dashboard object
returned by the embed SDK
we pass into the set options method the
new dashboard options that Define our
new layout the method sends a message to
the embedded dashboard to update its
options note that the embed SDK provides
the set options method as a convenience
to you you can instead call the send
method with the dashboard option set
message and the same options payload 2.
now when the user clicks on the button
the embedded dashboard receives a
message to dynamically update its layout
and there you have it we listened to the
dashboard loaded event emitted by the
iframe so we could understand the
dashboard's layout
then we determined the new dashboard
layout or rather which tile to hide
lastly we set up a new button to message
the iframe to update itself with the new
layout
now your user can dynamically change the
layout of the embedded dashboard from
within your host applications UI
we hope this use case gives you a
glimpse of the flexibility of looker
embedding we provide open source tools
like the looker embed SDK to help you
embed looker more easily
don't forget to try out the working
sample code in our looker embed
reference Repository
by the way everything I've mentioned
it's linked below and with that
look out for more videos in the series
see you next time
[Music]